[Musique]
la personne n'est pas n'est pas des
morts voilà
c'est ce que je voulais dire ils n'ont
pas meurtre mais c'est vrai que si coup
de couteau ça devient n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui jujudicaël pourquoi les
infirmières sont en galère à cause de
tout ça mais en fait là c'est typique de
ce qui se passe et vous parler d'un six
coups de couteau mais hier une
infirmière à la station a pris un coup
de marteau non ici sur Paris mais moi je
vous dis moi j'ai des potes
d'infirmières qui nous appellent qui se
font insulter dans les rares poux où on
a un accès prioritaire parce que accepte
qui dit accès prioritaire dit bien sûr
séparation entre les normalement les
gens prioritaires et les autres mais une
incompréhension donc il y a aucune
sécurisation on demande aux pompiers
aujourd'hui d'assurer la sécurité c'est
comme on a demandé avant dans les bars
au moment du coït de faire la police
bien sûr c'est pas à eux de faire la
police et il faut qu'il y ait des
stations qui soient
réquisitionnées ou au moins avec des
accès prioritaires partout là je viens
je viens d'apprendre juste avant
d'arriver là sur le plateau dans le Var
imaginez le Var pour l'ensemble des
professions prioritaires quatre pompes 4
pompes pour l'ensemble du vin c'est
n'importe quoi on se retrouve nous avec
des infirmières aujourd'hui qui ne
peuvent plus assurer leurs soins à
domicile alors je vais vous dire ce qu'a
dit la Premier ministre Premier ministre
dans un instant voilà Elisabeth borne
donc vous aujourd'hui même les les
infirmières aujourd'hui elles sont aussi
et c'était il y a plein il y a plein
d'autres métiers qui sont comme ça il y
a plein de gens qui ne peuvent pas
exercer leur métier actuellement et les
infirmières c'est très grave parce
qu'elles peuvent pas soigner les gens
voilà nous aujourd'hui on est obligé de
sélectionner dans nos dans nos tournées
de soins les soins qui sont priorités ou
pas mais ça c'est pas possible dans quel
pays on vit où on est obligé de
sélectionner les gens qu'on va se
soigner
on est obligé les cas graves parfois de
les renvoyer sur l'hôpital parce qu'ils
ont pas suffisamment de problèmes à
l'hôpital c'est fou et je vais vous dire
regardez la pénurie touche tout le monde
puisque vous parlez d'infirmières les
policiers et les militaires sont tombés
carrément en panne aussi regardez
donc 98 95 diesel il y a plus rien
je trouve on rigole mais vous vous
rendez compte est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte de ça on est considéré en
intervention les infirmières qui peuvent
façonner des gens non mais
Olivier Thomas pompiste explique-nous ce
qui se passe au l'idée
c'est totalement dramatique là un moment
où notre ils nous ont laissé tranquille
en septembre on a gagné notre vie
pendant trois semaines est-ce que Total
avait descendu 30 centimes de ça
on était en dessous des stations
services donc des grandes surfaces ça
fait 28 ans que ça m'est jamais arrivé
on a fait 70 ml à un mois trois semaines
et d'un seul coup il coupe les ponts
j'ai rien contre vous mais vous êtes
syndicaliste et dès l'instant où il y a
quelqu'un qui se met en place et quand
syndicat il a au milieu ça fait pas
avancer les choses et là pour l'instant
on est vraiment à l'arrêt total on peut
pas laisser la France comme ça c'est pas
possible vous avez vu ça alors il y a le
prix pour qu'on prenne les choses en
main
sur le sujet aujourd'hui lors d'un
déplacement Mayenne regardez
cette situation premièrement elle n'est
pas liée à la guerre du tout et
deuxièmement elle n'est pas le fait du
gouvernement je crois qu'il y a une
négociation qui sont en bonne voie pour
les prochaines heures mais j'appelle
aussi l'ensemble des entreprises
concernées de leur salarié à l'esprit de
responsabilité les négociations
salariales sont toutes légitimes il va
avoir tient pas d'en juger mais il faut
qu'elle trouve une conclusion pour que
en quelque sorte qu'il ne soit pas nos
compatriotes qui en soi les victimes le
blocage c'est pas une façon de négocier
mais vous comprendrez aisément que on va
pas rentrer dans une situation c'est le
président de la République qui va faire
les négociations salariales chez eux au
total parce que là on va partir cul par
dessus tête hein
il faut que là il faut que ça se bouge
après il y a Elisabeth borne je vous dis
réquisitionner alors
Élisabeth Premier ministre pourrait
prendre la décision de réquisitionner
les raffineries pour mettre fin aux
pénurie de carburant selon une source de
l'exécutif Matignon étudie toutes les
possibilités et celle-ci est très
sérieuse parce que c'est vrai que là
c'est incroyable aujourd'hui on voit
total énergie des milliards d'euros de
bénéfices 10 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices en un semestre
et nous il nous laisse dans la merde non
mais les gars
on peut dans ce pays toute façon comme
quelqu'un gagne de l'argent il dérange
c'est pas logique mais à un moment ou
non qui est quelque chose qui se fasse
c'est pas normal que les raffiner les
choses bloque tout et nous prennent en
montage c'est pas normal et c'est pas
logique comme a dit le président et là
je suis surprenant je suis d'accord avec
le président il faut que là qu'il trouve
une issue et c'est pas au président
d'aller faire une négociation ça fait
combien de temps qu'ils essayent de
négocier et que et que l'État est au
courant moi je lui demande pas d'aller
faire la négociation chez chez Total moi
je lui demande de faire son boulot de
président il y a un président qui avait
dit gouverné c'est prévoir les problèmes
chez Total ils sont au courant depuis
des mois des mois donc il sait très bien
qu'il y avoir au bout d'un moment le
dialogue social on sait très bien des
fois comment ça se termine ça se termine
c'est blocages donc il savait qu'il y
aurait des problèmes la majorité des
transporteurs des coursiers etc
maintenant ils ont des cartes totales
donc on savait en plus que là ça allait
créer un problème parce que tous ces
gens là ils veulent ils allaient bien
falloir pour qu'ils puissent travailler
qu'ils aillent s'approvisionner ailleurs
donc ils sont venus ils ont saturé
l'ensemble des autres stations
aujourd'hui ça a créé une pénurie en
plus il y a eu un vent de panique on a
vu ça on avait déjà eu ça avec le papier
toilette c'est incroyable nous dès qu'il
y a un problème c'est la panique vous
soyez là ce soit parce que pour tirer
les sonnettes d'alarme parce que voilà
on parle d'infirmière qui peuvent pas
les soigner des gens on parle de
policier on parle des pompiers
les pompiers et même la personne qui
travaille tous les jours pour gagner
pour son loyer travailler exactement
chez nous on est vite depuis 10 jours
c'est à dire pour gagner 0 donc le
camion pour 0 mais les voitures parce
qu'ils ont peur de tomber en panne
Haute-Loire donc 0 + 0 là on va dire la
tête à Toto au bout d'un moment ça
commence à suffire là vous me parlez de
négociation de toutes ces choses là
super ouais mais c'est bon c'est
toujours des bonbons il y a des belles
paroles vous savez que nous sur les
cartes gr par exemple c'est total qui
nous rétribue tous les 15 jours je
touche 75 ou 80 euros tous les 15 jours
pour les 4 gr donc en fait les cartes GR
sont pas prioritaires par rapport à
total nous on est là donc elle fantare
on travaille avec les cartes totales
s'ils viennent nous dilapider
c'est-à-dire tous les gendarmes les
pompiers et tout les services de
rapidité de proximité comme vous dites à
un moment ou un autre on aura plus de
carburant et on va gagner 75 euros tous
les 15 jours c'est pas logique c'est pas
normal est-ce que alors on sait que en
espagnol
de la transition énergétique qui est
très sympa d'ailleurs j'espère qu'elle
va venir nous voir prochainement sachez
qu'elle a la covid là pour l'instant
elle est en train de gérer la maison
là prochainement pour nous parler de la
situation peut-être demain auprès de moi
je sais pas quand elle peut venir mais
aujourd'hui il y a une vraie urgence
voilà je voulais absolument vous avoir
tous les deux aujourd'hui vous allez-y
les portes ouvertes du mars ou abrite ça
devait être avril on a fait une voiture
en portes ouvertes chez nous d'accord
chez moi
Opel qui avait pour pas citer de Marc
bien sûr électrique un a vendu 22 c'est
à dire que les gens sont en train de
changer de d'attitude par rapport à tout
ce qui se passe donc là je suis sûr qu'à
mon avis pour quand ils pourront pas les
livrer mais il va y avoir des problèmes
et les gens vont dire on va acheter ce
qu'il y a un total faux problème bien
sûr parce que il y aura un problème
d'énergie après avec l'électrique donc
si tout le monde se bloque on n'arrivera
jamais à avancer c'est pas possible je
suis nickel c'est qu'on règle le
problème de demain parce que moi demain
j'ai des soignants qui me disent demain
je peux plus aller soigner c'est ça et
donc il y a un gros problème de santé en
plus d'un problème d'approvisionnement
de carburant on va avoir un problème de
santé publique monsieur des travailleurs
qui peuvent plus aider d'ailleurs qui
peuvent plus aller bosser mais il y a un
moment aussi il va falloir prioriser le
fait de pas pouvoir aller bosser ouais
sauf que moi j'ai eu la benne discours
avec des femmes
pourra peut-être pas venir dans mon
officier
demain c'est des gens qui meurent et en
rappelant que il faut bouger les choses
que vite déjà on a décalé bien sûr parce
qu'on pouvait pas opérer
on peut pas les soigner des affaires non
mais c'est un truc de fou merci en tout
cas tous les deux d'avoir été là Olivier
on espère que ça va on va tout faire
pour que ça se règle au plus vite on
peut rien
mars bah c'est vrai ça bouge quand tu es
passé en mars exactement bouger quand tu
vas passer aujourd'hui j'espère que ça
va rebouger en tout cas merci à vous
deux d'être venu nous voir